our next guest has been having people
come up to him for a while now
saying i grew up watching you i loved
watching you you inspired me to want to
go and do this
i'm one of those people i grew up
watching our next guest
and wanting to do this because i watched
him so i don't feel so bad when i say
hey
i grew up watching rich eisen as i
welcome rich eisen on the rich eisen
show
appreciate you taking some time to be on
your show rich and i did grow up
watching you and i hope it
makes you feel okay you know what ben um
i will take it um every every day
uh is a new one and i appreciate it so
thanks man
what's happening man
i've had uh i've had a i've had a heck
of a
10 days uh last two weeks have been
something else that i wouldn't wish on
anybody and um i'm i'm
feeling better um i'm tired a lot
but um i'm feeling better thanks guys
i appreciate that yeah bud yeah rich
we've obviously been thinking about you
and sending you a lot of love
and i know you've been you know getting
healthy and
and focusing on on getting right but i
know you've also kind of keep
keeping tabs on the nba finals and
you're watching a little bit
i've seen you tweeting as well what are
your thoughts on giannis this morning
are you as inspired as we are
yeah you know what i'm i'm so happy for
him
it's just it's just so great
to see hard work and dedication
and karma all
rewarded and it's
you know um it's terrific to see
what he's done for himself um
and what he's done uh in believing in
in himself as well as the franchise in
the city that has drafted and adopted
him
um you know it was right around um
you know uh this point in last year's
nba season obviously not
calendar wise but as soon as the finals
was over the
the front and center conversation was
what will giannis do
what does he want to do would he want to
stay in milwaukee
and ride it out and trust their process
or will he go somewhere else you know
miami los angeles other places where
it's considered a better bet and shot
for him to win it all
and he decided to stay put and the moves
that were
made around him had a lot of question
marks the giroux holiday was is he a
championship
piece and bogdanovic deciding not to
go there or accept to go there and
um you know chris middleton
can he blossom into a threat that
keeps um giannis not having to do it all
by himself and the answer was yes
to all of them and uh it's just
great to see and i know that we were all
in on the chris paul narrative
and was this his time and it sure looks
like it
and monty williams being another
terrific human being who should be
rewarded
for the way that he's conducted himself
and the way that he's
handled um his hit what's gone on in his
personal life
um there were just so many great stories
but to see giannis
be the champion is amazing
and it's just a great feel-good story
like you said rich it's
karma winning out it's character over
ego
humility staying the course there's so
many life nuggets to take away from
giannis from this series we've all faced
tremendous
adversity in this last year or a year
and a half and
had to overcome things in our our own
lives and and giannis obviously an
example of that in his life
just a reminder that kindness wins out
as well you're part of a real cutthroat
business rich but you've always shown
kindness to all of us here in the studio
to people you interact with to work with
uh
talk to me about just the the idea of
being
kind in the world of sports which can so
often
uh you know look to celebrate those who
take a far more selfish approach
well i mean it's not just shellfish it's
it's also a world in which
you know um um anger controversy
um and um contrarian
um approaches are are get the attention
um so you know he is just
uh that's why i tweeted out a video of
him
from last year or pre-pandemic i think
it could be two years ago
of a little girl going up to him with
a jersey for him to sign at some signing
and
and you know he he
he he gets this folder
uh from this girl and she explains to
him that she's done a bunch of drawings
of him and she wanted him to have it
and he stopped doing what he was doing
and got up from
his table to go around and hug her
and she this little girl starts tearing
because her
her you know hero or someone she
looks up to and lionizes decided to just
do a common decent human thing which
many people don't expect of of
you know uh individuals who who are
put on a pedestal and that's why i
wanted to
send that video out better than the
video of me saying that i would never
have broken up last year
[Laughter]
don't worry rich we mentioned that
earlier ben
ben i know brockman and
tj are just really like champion at the
bit
to dig into that rather than the very
timed um approach to this interview you
have taken
yeah the uh the google machine is
working on overdrive here today
definitely mentioned that earlier rich
it's totally fine
my worst take ever i've already copped
to it i copped to it
um well in advance of this conversation
and uh deep in uh ago in the playoffs
um it really is um
my worst take ever and um
didn't take long didn't take long for
that to age poorly
nope um and what he's done is i mean
he's incredible we were even
having some bad takes on the subject
matter just a few
a couple weeks ago that he's he's such a
liability from the line that he's the
only superstar who has to give the ball
up or
the team can't create shots for him in
this
in the stretch run of important games
because he's such a liability
i mean last night in a close-out game in
front of his home fans to put up a 50
piece
and then shoot the way that he did from
the free-throw line
and then defend and play and fight
through
fatigue it really is one of the most
remarkable
nba final performances we've ever seen
and uh
good for him rich his leg like exploded
two and a half weeks ago he shouldn't
have been playing it's insane
it is i mean he's just 26 too which is
the which is the aspect
um i think that i don't know if it's
already
you know taken root but i think the next
few weeks will be but
that this is um his
nba you know like this is his time we
were saying that about
kawhi two years ago so we have to be
careful but kawhi decided to go
somewhere else
right um and he's not going anywhere
and neither are you know coach bud who
was supposed to be
you know if he'd lost that game seven to
the net he would be
you know out now he can
always get a reservation in the city of
milwaukee the rest of his life
you know so it is amazing how these
things work out
and you know giannis's um
freakish um athletic talent
is now matched by the heart
and soul of what it takes to
win and lead and congrats to
middleton and you know portis and
holliday and the rest of the team to
you know raise their games along with
him
ben lyon's on with rich this is the rich
eisen show rich
oftentimes as much as i love the nba
finals some sadness starts to seep in
the day after because i realize it's
going to be a while until we see
nba basketball however we're blessed
with the olympics coming up we're going
to see both team usa for the men
and women do their thing across the pond
so well basketball fans will get great
olympic basketball will also get a great
show tonight on nbc you're hanging out
with the jonas brothers
the olympic dreams often referred to
as the fourth jonas brother what's it
like hanging out with those guys and
tell us about the show tonight
well i did not hang with the guys let's
be i'll be straight up
um about that i did hang with terry
crews for quite some time though because
the
the jonas brothers uh tonight at eight
eastern time are gonna go
through three olympic sports that they
attempt
themselves and compete amongst
themselves
with some actual real deal olympians
to help them um coach them up in each
one of these
uh events um gymnastics
um uh bike riding and
uh hurdles and you know if
terry crews and i call the action if you
will and it's just a
a ton of fun it's just fun watching
these guys who are very famous
um little really try because
just like all of us they're competitive
and certainly amongst brothers
a bunch of red asses amongst each other
and it's a lot of fun
and terry crews is one of the best
humans on the planet
and i got to hang with him for quite
some time a couple of weeks ago when i
did this
and it's on tonight at 8 8 eastern and
that is the
first i think real uh olympic
event of the week on nbc is this tonight
at eight eastern time and um and that'll
be fun
it's gonna be it's one of those for the
family that you're not gonna
sit around and and you know wonder why
you're seeing something that would um um
it's good
fun family entertainment and fair
tonight
it's great well i think all of us
sitting at home watching these
events that maybe we don't keep as close
an eye on every four years but we fall
love
fall in love with again around the
olympics it's great for us at home to
see
civilians to see the joe bros go out
there and try and
compete with the hurdles or or the
balance beam
kind of reminds us of just how
incredible these olympic athletes are is
there one sport rich
that people might be surprised to hear
that you just become
fanatical about come olympic season oh
it's just everything
and that's what everyone loves about the
olympics right is we just
you know we just get into everything
because it's that
it's the olympics and um and there's so
much on the line
and there's so much pride on the line
and obviously we all have our
patriotic tendencies to just root for
our our country
and um you know that's why i think every
you know couple of years and
when you see nations you know uh convene
in soccer where ordinarily a fan in the
united states might not watch a soccer
game
uh just because they love the sport but
they do love the sport and they love the
steaks
um when it's time for euro or it's time
for
uh the world cup that's what to me the
olympics is about and
it'll be exciting you know i'm fired up
about it there are a few phrases rich
that when thrown out kind of signify the
end of summer
you know little league world series back
to school sale
training camp opens training camp
training camp opens tomorrow
summer is starting to end tomorrow we're
in the heart of summer the
you know the nba finals it's kind of an
anomaly this time of year we got the
summer olympics but training camp
opens tomorrow so tell me how that makes
you feel knowing that the cowboys and
steelers are going to be
putting on pads and working out tomorrow
in an nfl season is upon us
well i mean obviously it's it's the
beginning of
um you know so many
story lines every year there's story
lines that last an entire year
it's what we call the season-long
storyline arc the nfl
being such a week-to-week league there's
week to week story lines that play into
the
season-long storyline arc and i think
you know
we talked about it on the show just a
couple weeks after
the super bowl it really is tom brady's
nfl
and not just tom brady's nfl in terms of
can
he repeat but the way that he has
succeeded
in tampa has created so many fault lines
and so many other
organizations and so
from many organizations seeing you know
obviously there's only one tom brady but
maybe we are just
one player at the quarterback position
away
making a change away from having that be
the difference
between finishing 500 or winning a
division
and winning it all from matthew stafford
to obviously that affecting jared goff
to carson wentz to um other franchises
that decided to draft the quarterback
now
um moving up to go get a quarterback
like the 49ers which we subsequently
learned as a plan b
for them they really were in on stafford
2
that maybe uh other teams like the jets
decided to go with a younger guy than
sam
donald was already young enough um to
um the the storyline of what happened
with russell wilson in seattle even
though he's still in seattle
the whole season will be viewed as
through the prism of what he said in
february to lead to march
trade rumors and then there's the mother
lode and aaron rodgers
then and that uh we're going to begin to
get
some answer in terms of his presence
physically or not to the question that
is still
without an answer and that is what does
aaron rodgers
want um if he wants to get out of green
bay right now i
don't believe he will get that exit visa
because
green bay would rather hold on to rogers
let him sit through an entire season out
if that's really what he wants to do
and then trade him for draft choices
that a team will give them a topic wrap
as opposed to giving them the exit visa
now
taking those draft choices and watch
rogers make those draft choices
worse for green bay that's just not
going to happen
so training camp is just the beginning
of so many incredible story lines and
stories and
you know i'm i i can't wait i'm so fired
up
i'm glad you're feeling fired up i'm
glad you're feeling better
and you'll be part of all the coverage
of course around the nfl
starting next week and return to the
show i can't thank you enough for this
opportunity i will forever hold these
nba finals
in a special place in my heart because i
will remember having to come in here
every morning
and and clown around with these dudes
and analyze these games so a special
place in my heart i thank you for that
let's let's first of all it's my
pleasure
and thank you for doing it and secondly
it is not the last time
that you will do it and i will make this
pledge to prove to you
that it won't take long is that the next
time you do it does not have to be
when the knicks make the nba final so
the door is open well that would that
was the case rich he'd never do it
yeah as long as as long as ex-nics stay
winning titles then i know i have a
chance so bobby portis once again
congratulations
there you go thanks rachel olympic
dreams tonight featuring the jonas
brothers riches hosting alongside terry
crews on
nbc at eight o'clock on the east coast
all right brothers
thank you for bringing it in on the rich
eisen show kind of him
glad to hear he's doing well yeah fired
up for the nfl the olympics
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here